all right so Andor season one has now
come to a close giving us one heck of an
explosive conclusion and in this video
we're going to be discussing the ins and
outs of this episode our predictions for
what season 2 has in store along with
our general thoughts of this series as a
whole anyway thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into Andor episode
12. I've been turning away from the
truth I want it not to face
there is a wound that won't heal at the
center of the Galaxy the Empire is a
disease that thrives in darkness it is
never More Alive than when we sleep
first off though we gotta talk about
something that you might have missed if
you didn't stick around through the
credits yes unlike the previous episodes
this finale actually ends with a huge
reveal in a post-credits scene as we see
none other than the Death Star being
constructed this is something week in a
week out we had kind of theorized was
being built or at least components of it
were being built by the prisoners on
narkina 5. as we see it being assembled
similar to the ending of Revenge of the
Sith we get confirmation that the items
that Andor and his work crew buddies
were piecing together actually helped to
assemble the dish section of the Death
Star as we know the Death Star plays
massively into Rogue one as it's the
main threat and the entire film revolves
around Andor and jyn urso stealing the
plans for it ironically enough Andor is
killed by the laser from its firing
meaning that he helped to assemble the
very thing that would kill him it is
interesting to see the progress of the
build over the what you know 14-ish
years between a Revenge of the Sith and
Andor here it's almost complete with
only the dish and I'm assuming the
multiple kyber crystals being left
however with the Prison Breaks labor and
parts slowed down causing the completion
of the dish to take roughly five years
to finally insert into the Death Star
man I am I'm so glad the Empire knows
the struggle of taking five years to get
it in a and now because of the events of
Rogue one we know the Death Star will
not be operational until much later in
the Star Wars timeline and Andor won't
really be aware of it until that film he
does discover that the Empire is
building a planet-killing weapon of some
kind but he doesn't know the ins and
outs of it this means Andor won't find
out about the Death Star in season 2 but
that doesn't necessarily mean that any
of the other characters can't luthin is
of course a major part of the series and
for being such a pivotal figure in the
rebellion's infancy there's only really
one reason he wouldn't be around for the
events of Rogue one
he's uh well he's dead unfortunately I
think Lutheran is gonna die in the next
season and this could be a result of him
learning of the Death Star this would
tie in with the opening of Rogue one as
we see him passing along the info about
the defective pilot to Daniel May's
character of tivick tivick could then
head out to Catherine to meet with Andor
which could then be a way to end season
two similarly mirroring how Rogue one
butts right up against the events of A
New Hope either way I don't think
Lutheran is making it out of this alive
and this would explain why such a
prominent member of the Rebellion isn't
anywhere to be seen in the rest of the
Star Wars timeline unless Disney wants a
special edition Rogue one CGI Lutheran
into scenes I mean that would be awful
but hey we we have seen worse he's of
course masquerading as an Antiquities
dealer on Coruscant and hey it's even
possible that he could end up blowing
his own cover in order to buy time for
mon mothma to escape knowing all too
well she plays a bigger role in the
grander Rebellion than he does unlike
him she is in the rest of the Saga and
she's openly helping the Rebellion
instead of hiding away so I'm guessing
she gets exposed by Devo skalden and due
to her closeness to Lutheran she could
end up accidentally exposing him too
we're going to talk about it more in the
rest of the video but if you're a simp
Ariel like surreal then please hit that
thumbs up button and make sure to
subscribe to join the Jared Rebellion
against the evil emperor Paul patine hey
join we got some fruit snacks now the
Death Star is a big way to close out
this season but how did we get there
well for the next part of the video I
want to talk about the build up to to
that Cliffhanger and also go over the
directions that we might see the start
of season two going with Lutheran huge
spoiler alert but we found out that
luthin is actually this kid from the
Jedi Temple I'm just messing with you
but how insane would that be he's aged
horribly but Lutheran doesn't kill and
or surprise surprise the whole episode
had been all of these various parties
flocking to ferrics to tie up the loose
end of Cassian though the end when
luthin is given the opportunity to kill
him he doesn't because he sees the fight
in him and the line from Andor says so
much about where we know his journey
takes him
kill me
or take me in
Andor has lost everything he has nowhere
to go either he's going to fight the
Empire with everything he has got or
just you know end it right there there
is no point in living we know he goes
with the prior which does lead to his
eventual death but that doesn't stop him
from becoming a notable member in the
rebel cause Lutheran scene Andor has the
same Spirit he possesses matching the
incredible speech from episode 10 with
Lonnie luthan Smiles knowing his hunch
regarding Andor all the way back in
episode 3 was right so not only in a way
does Andor now have a purpose to live
but luthin is no longer this lonely
person haven't given everything up the
two have each other and a shared goal
now the series being titled Andor is
fitting because sure we know Cassian
goes on with these grander things but
Marva even after her death was still
fighting she was another spark that
helped rally the people of ferrics to
stand up against the empire with the
help of b fairix along with the word of
narkina 5 are no doubt spreading rally
rallying I cannot even rallying others
for the cause with a handful of them
hopping on board a transport ship
escaping only shows me that a couple of
them will probably end up in season two
having been seasoned no longer sleeping
but fighting even harder against the
empire this also shows how scared and
unprepared the Empire is with people
actually standing up against them the
Troopers but more importantly Miro
unexpectedly distraught by the events
that transpired lastly mothma appears to
be going along with the Devo skaldron
meeting despite her own judgment she did
however cleverly create an excuse
earlier in the episode concerning the
missing money blaming her husband with
his gambling problems the Imperial
driver's spy passed along this
information to blevin who appears to
have been behind the whole surveillance
operation against Ma from the beginning
being the politician she is this was a
clever because not only has she kind of
created this fake excuse with the
gambling winnings but also moved forward
with the skaldrin arrangement this
allows her to take the money from him
cover her tracks but if she is caught
and then she's easily able to blame her
husband in skalden allowing for the eyes
to finally be taken off of her man what
a plan as her daughter though I don't
think that there's any way around her
not having them wet Leta being adamant
about chandrillen tradition and against
anything her mother wants so her Union
with skaldrin's son feels inevitable now
where does season 2 of Andor go is the
million dollar question originally Tony
Gilroy and crew had Andor mapped out to
five season with each of these Seasons
covering a year before the events of
Rogue one however things were kind of
condensed from Five Seasons down to two
with season one roughly taken place in
the year of bby5 or five years before
the Battle of Yavin that means that
season 2 has about four years of the
Star Wars timeline it can cover Gilroy
continued in an interview stating that
season one was developed in blocks of
Three episodes and that season two would
follow the same three block structure
with each block covering a different
year time jumps folks where we're going
we wait that's the wrong franchise uh
Hyper Speed we're going hyperspace to
the Future this can allow for us to see
characters taking on major events in a
couple of days or maybe even weeks and
then jumping a whole year as we see them
as a completely different character like
they have seen some
the next four years aren't necessarily
about the Rebellion they're about
learning to be a leader and how
difficult it is to put an alliance
together and what happens to these
people who are the original gangsters
versus The Establishment and a lot of
different issues Gilroy continues
stating that roughly 30 some characters
are being carried forward to season two
in the second half of the series is
about what does time do to these people
people grow and people get tired people
betray one another people change their
minds people get weak and people go
cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs so all of this
combined with the time jumps could see
someone desperately on board with the
rebel cause an episode and what three
only to see them siding with the Empire
a year later in episode 4. as for who or
what is going to show up are only
theories but no doubt fan favorite
k2so motion captured and voiced by Alan
Tudyk will be introduced as The Lovable
reprogrammed Imperial Security Droid we
know from Rogue one he could show up
after one of the time Jump sections or
even get an actual meeting and
reprogramming of him by Cassian and the
twins of rismore and Curtis on WE cuckoo
what what who's naming these planets
like we mentioned earlier Lutheran plays
a big role in the rebellion's beginnings
but his absence in any of the films
almost guarantees he's gonna die the
amount of time energy money life he has
given to the cause ties back to the
emotional speech in episode 10 and his
sacrifice honestly might be for mothma
covering for her knowing all too well so
that she has more leadership qualities
than he a key moment for mothma will be
the public challenge of the emperor and
the Empire over the Gorman Massacre back
in episode 6 mothma mentions the
peaceful protest of Gorman having a knee
on their neck over basic rights however
her efforts failed resulting in the
massacre which saw Imperial Troopers
killing hundreds of peaceful protests I
believe this happens in bby2 so it's got
to be included because this is what
drives mothma on the path of becoming a
public figure standing against the
empire later resigning from the Senate
and becoming the prominent member of the
Rebellion we know working with several
characters featured in Rebels leaving
her family behind because Devo skaldrin
and her husband have tainted definitely
tainted her daughter speaking of rebels
yeah almost all of these characters are
fair game to make their live action
appearance you get a cameo and you get a
cameo everyone gets a cameo
nah it won't be a cameo Fest of an MCU
movie but rather the key members that
are operating in the Rebellion kind of
makes sense for them to show up Hera who
ends up becoming a high ranking member
in the Rebellion seems like a safe bet
along with some of her maybe Associates
I'm banking on Sabine but honestly it
could be the whole crew as for the
Imperial side of things brawny thrawny
is no doubt going to make an appearance
this time in the Star Wars timeline begs
him to be a destructive force for the
Empire and task with tracking down the
rebel activity which he is obviously
very very good at Not only would it be a
great way to introduce this blue man to
a wider audience but even could be the
person that surreal ends up reporting to
surreal and Miro seem to be going on the
path of Imperial power couple performing
the old Trench Run in the bedroom but
the thirst for power is going to drive
surreal up the ranks while I'm
theorizing the opposite is going to see
Miro distancing herself from the Empire
the traumatic field work on ferric shows
her first hand what the Empire is
capable of and this rattles her loose
from the Empire's hold now some final
thoughts on season 2 includes either a
name drop or maybe an appearance by
krennic who becomes you know head of the
Death Star project and Galen urso at
least passing along the Death Star
information to Bodhi Rook with Gilroy
getting into the grittiness of
everything this could even make for one
of the three episode kind of block arcs
and lastly Jimmy Smith's Bale or Ghana
baby he's gonna be back don't you worry
along with Tarkin being the thorn in
krennic's side that we kind of see in
Rogue one oh yeah and Yavin 4 will no
doubt be the base of operations in the
later half of the season this plays a
large role and would be foolish not to
include in some capacity like I said
earlier the final moments will no doubt
lead directly to the opening of Rogue
one much like Rogue one did to A New
Hope I'm hoping season 2 will be the
same caliber as season one part of me
did really want five seasons of this
each tackling one single year I mean
give me the nitty-gritty of the
Rebellion as it's building down to every
single minute detail but hey I'm not
gonna complain about anything in Andor
because it was fantastic but what do you
think what Star Wars characters do you
hope might show show up in season two
and why is it an old grizzled calcestus
surprisingly the chatter I've seen
online about Andor well well
unfortunately it's not much which is a
shame because this series is by far the
most interesting well-crafted serious
take on Star Wars since the property was
bought up by the mouse Monopoly heck I
even think this is the best thing since
the original trilogy Star Wars doesn't
have to be just for kids and or being
the more mature example of this that
with great talent in front and behind
the camera less lightsaber action more
character development and less Reliance
on CGI we can explore these new planets
and characters and relationships without
popping in a squibble beep Cameo for
people to scream let's go it's the
tension and drama in these relationships
that have elevated every single episode
leading to this finale and I am so much
more invested in Andor and kinoloi
escaping a state-of-the-art prison than
say Boba Fett teaching sand people how
to ride Speeders Tony Gilroy perfectly
introduced so many new characters with
all of their storylines weaving
perfectly together there isn't a single
through line that feels terribly weak
compared to the others and the synth
Space Opera blade runner-esque score
from bertel bred new life into what Star
Wars has been known to be less Reliance
on the old and Nostalgia it almost
worked too well here are we still doing
numbers with these review sections yet
yet we we are okay well Misa gonna give
Andor a solid 9.5 out of 10. all around
fantastic season it blew away my
expectations and easily climbed up there
with my love for rogue one I would say
the only nitpick is that the first three
episodes need to be watched together as
almost one big movie watching one
doesn't necessarily have the same impact
and honestly kinda is a slow start but
man every episode I'm telling you every
single episode gets better and better
which is almost impossible Tony Gilroy
and crew should be ecstatic about what
they created and I cannot wait for what
season 2 has in store but obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on episode 12
of Andor that post-credits scene and do
you think that this is the best thing
that Disney has done with the Star Wars
property and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition right
now giving away three copies of House of
dragons season one on the 15th of
December and all you have to do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below on your
thoughts of Andor episode 12. we picked
the comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of last month are
on screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos like our Loki season 2 leaked
trailer breakdown with that audio away
thanks for your constant support I've
been Jared and remember Andor is awesome
awesome I'll see you in the next one
take care and peace